vos petits enfants ont fait leur rentrée
des classes la semaine dernière les
nôtres n'ont jamais vu d'école où se
souviennent à peine de leur maîtresse
c'est par ces mots que débute la lettre
du collectif des familles unies adressée
à emmanuel macron est publié dans le
parisien un appel soutenu par 76
parlementaires dont des eurodéputés tous
réclament le rapatriement des enfants
français retenus dans des camps syrien
auprès de leur mère jihadistes je suis
l'une des soixante seize élus demandant
le retour des enfants de nationalité
française victime de traitements
inhumains ainsi que de leur mère retenus
dans des camps en syrie il s'agit là
d'un impératif humanitaire et
sécuritaire
j'ai signé cette tribune de trop
nombreux enfants français croupissent
encore dans ces camps en syrie ne pas
les rapatriés n'est pas digne de la
france
la politique du cas par cas n'a plus de
sens
nous sommes de plus en plus de
parlementaires à soutenir le
rapatriement des enfants de syrie
nous ne pouvons pas détourner le regard
la france a une responsabilité
particulière et doit l'assumer
j'ai signé cet appel avec 76
parlementaires pour que la france
rapatrie immédiatement les enfants
français victimes de traitements
inhumains et dégradants qui périssent
dans les camps syriens et leur mère
selon les estimations de l'unicef près
de 29000 enfants étrangers seraient à ce
jour retenu en syrie parmi eux près de
200 seraient français selon le collectif
des familles unies la plupart pourraient
être détenus dans les camps de réfugiés
d'al hall situé au nord-est du pays dans
des conditions humanitaires déplorable
les conditions sanitaires dans
lesquelles survivent ces enfants sont
parfaitement indigne
plus de 300 enfants sont décédés dans le
sol quand dallol en 2019 et des dizaines
d'enfants sont morts de malnutrition de
déshydratation d'arrêt cardiaque et
d'hémorragies internes depuis le début
de l'été au nom de l'impératif
humanitaire nous parlementaires appelons
la france à rapatrier immédiatement les
enfants français victimes de traitements
inhumains et dégradants qui périssent
dans les camps syrien en finir avec la
politique du cas par cas prônée par
l'état français c'est ce que réclament
ces élus et le collectif des familles
unies depuis le printemps 2010 9 28
enfants ont été rapatriés dans
l'hexagone
outre le volet humanitaire les
signataire de cette lettre évoquent
l'aspect sécuritaire selon eux les mères
des enfants doivent elles aussi être
rapatriés les évasions sont monnaie
courante dans ces camps et ces femmes
restent à la merci de dèche
les rapatriés permettrait à la justice
française de les juger et de les
condamner
depuis des mois des chapelles
publiquement ses partisans à libérer ces
femmes pour mieux les enrôler et faire
grossir ses rangs les camps de roms et
dallol sont des foyers de violence et de
radicalisation extrêmement dangereux et
l'instabilité de cette zone nous oblige
à rapatrier la centaine de femmes
françaises qui sont détenus pour le
moment le gouvernement ne semble pas
avoir changé de cap sur la question la
classe politique elle aussi peinent à se
mettre d'accord et 7 à droite de
l'échiquier que se trouvent les opinions
défavorables au rapatriement des enfants
et de leur mère non retour des
djihadistes organisé par macron
aujourd'hui encore trois jihadistes et
leurs neuf enfants ont été rapatriés de
turquie ces individus ont fait le choix
de prendre les armes contre la france
qu'ils soient donc jugé en irak ou en
syrie peut-on vraiment rapatrier des
enfants de djihadistes de 16 ans utilisé
comme arme de guerre par l'état
islamique
l'accueil des enfants doit se faire au
cas par cas papa trip sur lci
j'expliquais que pour saisir l'enjeu du
rapatriement des enfants de djihadistes
l'hypothèse de départ doit être que
l'islamisme est un nazisme placé en camp
d'entraînement dès l'âge de 3 ans les
enfants jihadistes sont comme la hitler
jungen des bombes humaines
ludovic rivière avocat au barreau de
toulouse est l'un des signataires de la
tribune selon lui le choix du
gouvernement de ne procéder au cas par
cas serait motivée par un objectif
électoraliste
c'est en tout cas ce qu'il a confié à
nos confrères de l'express évoquant je
cite la soumission d'un gouvernement à
l'opinion publique selon un sondage aux
hawks aden sud consulting pour le figaro
et france info paru l'année dernière
67% des personnes interrogées souhaitent
laisser les enfants de jihadistes en
irak et en syrie